lee pace is a happily married man yes
the body's body's body start revealed in
a new interview with gq hype that he and
his now former boyfriend officially tied
the knot lee shared with the mag that he
and his partner matthew fowley and
executive at tom brown were actually set
up by a mutual friend sharing quote i
said to my friend nick you know a lot of
people who do you have for me and it
luckily has worked out now the actor
couldn't help but gush about his husband
and married life saying quote it was
once described to me as an endless
sleepover with your weirdest friend in
our experience that is absolutely true
if you found one person you can be weird
around hold on tight whitley adding i'd
love to have kids i think there's
nothing better than little kids running
around i brought something what is it
it's zucchini bread
yum before taking on the role as a
father lee's next big project is the
upcoming horror comedy bodies bodies
bodies where he stars alongside pete
davidson who he said he loved working
with revealing i found him as a human
being fascinating his stories were
interesting his approach to the work was
serious and interesting i don't watch
saturday night live so i don't know what
he does on saturday night live but in
that context i was like you're cool and
i really am curious to see what things
you do in your career
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos